للملياردير الامريكي مؤسس شركه مايكروسوفت
بيل جيتس حصه من اخبارنا اليوم وهذه
الاخبار حقيقه صادمه ومؤسر ابدا
اللي كانت سنوات او انتهت سنوات ال 27 من
الزواج بالطلاق من زوجته ميلاندا يعني
بيواجه فضيحه وورطه نقدر نعانونها بفضيحه
خيانه وابتزاز ففي تقرير كشفت عنه
علاقه وهو متزوج مع الرياضيات الروسيه
ميله انوفا اللي تعرف عليها في 2010 ومو
بس كده الصادم انه تعرض لابتزاز بيخص
علاقته بالفتاه الروسيه وللتهديد بكشف هذه
العلاقه من شخص بالتاكيد ما في احد يتمنى
انه يرتبط اسمه فيه وهو رجل الاعمال راحل
جفري ابستين اللي احاطت فيه مصايب وفضائح
الدنيا كلها من تحرج وتجاره بشر وابتزاز
وغيرها وكان تم القبض عليه ومات في السجن
بظروف غامضه اغلبها بيقول انه انتحر اللي
صار انه من بعد عام 2008 وسمعته انهدمت
بسبب قضيه تحرش وبقاصر قرر يعمل صندوق
خيري بمليارات الدولارات علشان يجمل سمعته
ويعيد بنائها وكان بيل جيت من الاشخاص
اللي ضمن القائمه لكن ما قدر يقنع جيت
بانه يساهم في الصندوق وعلشان كده هددوا
واللي بيسال طب ايش دخل الفتى الروسيه في
لانه بكل بساطه راحت لعند 2013 وعملت دوره
برمجه وما دفعت فلوس لانه اتكفل بتدريبها
بالكامل ولكن بعد ما عرفت بعلاقتها مع بيل
جيتس صار بيهددوا بفتح العلاقه لو ما شارك
في الصندوق الخيري وهذا اللي صار لكن يعني
مو هو عايش وهو ميت
[موسيقى]